[Music]
hello everyone and welcome back to the
good stuff we are continuing the uh 1858
clash between paul charles morphy and
adolf anderson so the morphe saga
and it's the the fifth game of the
second match so if you've been following
what's happening so far more people won
the first match the the big one and now
while the photographers are getting
ready to take their photo they are
already playing the fifth game so as
some of you noticed in the comments uh
luckily it took such a long time to take
take a photo otherwise this match would
never happen and we would not have this
beautiful six games featuring only the
king's gambit so this is i believe the
most famous game from the second match
some of you have seen it some of you
haven't but for those of you who will
see it for the first time uh get ready
because well it's going to be a real
treat and it will definitely improve
your sunday or maybe a monday if you're
not watching this
maybe right now
uh so without further ado let's check it
out morphe has the white pieces and he
opens with e4 this does not come as a
surprise to you as it's uh you know six
games of the king's gambit sorry about
that
uh and anderson replies with e5 we have
f4 the king's gambit is on the board e
captures on f4 anderson accepts the
gambit knight to f3 and the g5 we
already mentioned the strongest reply
for black uh and then now comes h4 by
morphe we have g4 and knight to e5 and
we've already seen all of this if you
we're not going to be discussing all of
the line since we've covered most of
them in the previous videos of this
match uh so if you haven't uh uh seen
seen the other uh games for from this
match do check it out to understand this
a little bit better knight to f6 and now
knight captures on g4 and now there are
well some moves that you can play here
some moves you can't anderson tried some
that you really can't but here he goes
for the absolute best continuation
knight captures on e4 uh we have d3
challenging uh uh anderson's knight
knights the g3 now attacking the rook
and the bishop captures on f4 and this
is the first moment uh where we have to
uh well check what what do you do
basically our candidate moves our knight
captures rook and maybe queen to e7
check first maybe trade off the queens
and then capture the rook so let's see
what's happening if queen to e7 check
now well it's uh it's a fine move uh
anderson is already down four points in
the match so uh maybe trading queens
this early on in the game doesn't really
help him but it's a it's a really funny
line so i will show it let's say bishop
to e2 queen to b for check now we're
gonna block with the queen and now you
can't capture the pawn and go after the
rook because bishop to e5 check just
wins the game for white the knight here
nicely defends this bishop so instead
you would have to go for a queen trait
here and after let's say king captures
and b2 black would grab the rook but now
comes knight to f6 check king to d8 and
now knight to d5 going after the c7 pawn
uh black would defend it and now we get
bishop to g5 uh check and the while
black could uh somehow try to avoid uh
going into a perpetual here maybe with
knight with king to e7 uh it doesn't
look like something that black would be
willing to do so most likely what we
would see here is a nice perpetual
knight b5 opens up a discovery then we
repeat and we have another perpetual
so after bishop captures an f4 anderson
uh doesn't really enjoy this queen to e7
move so he goes for knight captures on
h1 and okay now morphy plays queen to e2
with check and you have to block with
the queen if you block with the bishop
then it's just a very quick checkmate
knight f6 check the bishop cannot
capture the uh it's pinned king to f8
and now bishop to h6 will be checkmate
the knight covers this bishop covers
this knight covers this so yeah
obviously you can't go there so anderson
has to block with the queen but it
doesn't matter still knight to f6 check
king to d8 and now there is only one
good move for morphe here so feel free
to pause the video and try to find this
idea while i give you a couple of
seconds
so for those of you who are able to do
it congratulations on spotting it it's
not a winning move but it's the only
move that allows whites to stay in the
game so to all of you who found it
congratulations as its bishop captures
on c7 with check the king now has no
squares uh your only move is to capture
the bishop so king captures bishop and
now morphe delivers knight to d5 check
for king the king and the queen and
while this seems like uh okay anderson
should just resign now and not really
because after king to d8 morphy grabbed
the queen bishop captures on e7 and we
get this position where yes morphy has a
queen but anderson has a rook uh uh dark
square bishop and a knight for or rather
we can choose this knight uh for a queen
so it's not bad two beasts and a rook
are definitely better than a queen the
problem for anderson is that all of his
pieces are still undeveloped and this
knight still has to figure out how to
get back into the game and morphe plays
queen to g4 he takes away the g3 square
from anderson's knight and is planning
to win it queen h3 will capture the
knight and that's it then morphy will
simply be up material and interestingly
uh this position uh happened uh uh also
a year after this game was played but
anderson had the white pieces only he
didn't go queen to g4 he played queen to
h5 and he won a very nice game against
the bertolt chula in
his hometown of brazlav where uh where
he came from to visit morphe here in
paris but here morphe played queen to g4
and now comes uh just uh well a nice d6
attacking the queen and also taking away
the h3 square for the white queen we
have queen to f4 now uh going after the
f7 pawn but uh on the senses i i have to
develop i don't really care about pawns
now uh rook to g8 and now knight is
coming to g3 that's the point so morphy
has to do something he plays queen
captures on f7 now threatens to pick up
the rook but now bishop captures an h4
with check king to d2 uh sorry king to
d2 uh and now comes uh rook to e8 and
here morphy has to decide how to
continue this game and it's not an easy
choice because uh well of course you
want to develop but if you just continue
knight to c3 and think you're getting a
rook into the game not really the bishop
is covering the e1 square uh and just
bishop g5 check you've just blocked the
c3 square sir king doesn't have anywhere
to go the rook covers these these three
squares uh bishop covers c1 it's uh well
king the d1 knight is coming to g3 it's
just looking very ugly for white and
another thing after rook to a8 morphe
could go for queen to h5 seems like it's
winning the bishop is attacked and if
the bishop moves we win the knight the
problem is there's this bishop the e1
check and now after the king moves uh
we're gonna play knights the g3 attack
the queen get our pieces into the game
and the black is just uh well pretty
much winning now because there's no way
to win that knight
uh so after rook to e8 morphy plays
knight to a3 uh now it's a little bit
better uh since uh bishop the g5 will be
met with king to c3 but this is
something that black should do
nonetheless because if bishop g5 king c3
then we simply continue developing
bishop to d7 and uh well although it's
looking pretty shaky i mean the king is
still on d8 uh it's it's it's actually
perfectly fine for black if knight's the
c4 going after the pawn we defended king
c7 if queen to d5 going after the pawn
bishop to f4 and black is holding this
uh but anderson after knight to a3
played knight the a6 and this is now a
problem because now morphy just goes for
it queen to h5 now this is possible as
uh well there's there is no bishop to e1
with check the the rook covers that
square and there is no bishop g5 the
queen covers that so here we have bishop
to f6 by anderson and now morphy simply
picks up the knight on h1 uh there's
also a fun line that
starts with rook the e1 because we're
now threatening to pick up the rook here
anderson would have to trade captures
captures you get a knight into the game
but now queen to f7 goes after the
bishop and only after the bishop moves
now we go knight to b5 and now we're
controlling a lot of critical squares
here and we're going to start winning
some of the pieces because there are so
many chicks in the position and we're
going to be able to pick up
at least at least one of these pieces if
bishop the d7 attacks the knight we're
going to deliver queen to g8 to check uh
and after the bishop blocks now we
simply play queen to g5 check came to c8
and now we pick up the the knight on g3
and now the problem is if bishop
captures here then we deliver queen to
ga to check and we pick up the rook here
so white will always be up material
it was another way
of treating the position instead of
morphe's direct queen captures on h1 uh
but okay here anderson has to figure out
how to continue and he plays bishop
captures on b2 and this will simply not
to do another one way that could allow
him to continue is bishop to g5 check
but this entire game is so complicated
that we could simply show lines uh you
know endlessly but i'm gonna show this
one as it's also very nice king to c3
and now bishop to e6 and it really seems
like anderson uh has morphy's king on
the run bishop covering all of these
scores the knight covering this the rook
coming to c8 but morphy would be able to
defend with b3 it looks very ugly but it
works bishop f6 check now we played d4
and only after rook the c8 checked now
we play king back to b2 and allow the
capture of the d4 pawn bishop captures
king to b1 we've escaped and white
should be better here even though it
looks incredibly ugly but
it's definitely black's best uh
way of trying to defend this position so
instead after queen captures on h1
anderson doesn't find this uh idea of
bishop to g5 he plays bishop captures on
b2 i mean who wouldn't uh and now morphy
simply finds the quickest way to victory
queen to h4 with check king to d7 and
now rook to b1 that's that's the good
stuff uh anderson captures the knight
here and now we have queen the a4 with
check and he was in this position uh on
move 23 that adolf anderson resigned the
game so interestingly morphy wins all of
his games with white uh in less than 25
moves first with white in 19 second with
white also in 19 and third now with the
white pieces in 23 moves
and it doesn't really matter what you
play here if you move the king away from
the defense of the rook we simply
capture the rook if you go king to a7 we
play rook to e1 check and then capture
the rook and if you try to defend with
king to d8 it's not a problem we're just
going to capture on a3 attacking the d6
pawn and there's no good way to defend
this
whatever you try uh you can't move the
bishop the b7 pawn falls uh it's just
really really ugly if rook to e6 we're
gonna play d4 now prepare bishop to c4
and if knight to c7 now trying to get
some pieces into the game we attack the
rook bishop to c4 let's say rook to g6
and now queen to f3 and that's it there
is no good reply here uh you can't
really move anything if the bishop moves
we capture on b7 that the rook can't
really move anywhere we're we're really
going for that f8 square and if knight
the e8 then we simply play rook to e1
and again black is simply into too big
of a
uh
almost uh because whatever you play here
simply
uh just you know ruins ruins uh your
position there really is no way to play
this bishop to f7 can be played
attacking the the rook and the knight
it's i mean it's just ugly you could
play rook captures followed by bishop to
f7 check you pick up the rook uh there
are you know some lines are good some
are better but all of them are winning
so after queen to a for check
anderson resigned and this is morphy's
fifth victory in a row in the second
match which leaves us only with one more
game while the photographers are getting
ready to take their photo so will this
match end by you know
well a fisher result of a 6-0 or will we
have a nice comeback by anderson uh stay
tuned and check it out in the next
episode of the morphe saga
so yeah that's the game hope you guys
enjoyed it the very nice kings gambit
adventure you know always play the
king's gambit uh i would like to thank
online by more dimitra angelo sean vijay
luke sims and barry barton for your
contribution to my channel thank you a
lot to really appreciate it as usual you
can check to all my previous videos here
thank you for watching and i will see
you soon continuing the coverage of the
morphe saga uh until it ends uh so thank
you i will see you soon and have an
excellent rest of your day